Hi everyone. Thanks for being here.
I am Sohaib here and along with me is
Ankush. So, today we'll be talking about
a mistake that looks harmless at first.
Giving which is basically giving an AI
agent every tool access it might ever
need all at once.
So, basically that approach works well
in a demo.
It might even work with a small number
of tools like like say for example 10
tools. But once the catalog grows,
the agent gets slower. It might become
more expensive and less accurate as
well.
That is why we are calling it the 100
tool agent trap. In the next half an
hour or so, we'll show why it breaks,
what the numbers look like, and how
semantic routing with just-in-time
context can help us fix this problem.
So, a quick introduction about myself. I
am Sohaib Shaikh. I'm currently working
as a data scientist with Presodica. My
background spans across AI, NLP,
marketing, analytics, and even
engineering.
My current focus is on applied AI, NLP,
and conversational intelligence along
with rack systems. I'm especially
interested in making AI systems more
reliable, measurable, and even scalable
beyond the demos in production.
>> And I'm Ankush Astogi. I work as a
senior data solutions engineer at
Presodica.
I have spent more than a decade in AI,
data engineering, and production
systems.
My
focus is the engineering side. So, it's
not about what's going to work in
notebook, but whether it's going to
survive in
with real load, real user, and real
failures. So, that is the angle we are
taking today.
Suhail will focus more on the model and
routing behavior, and I will focus more
on system design, implementation, and
production trade-offs.
>> Awesome. Thank you, Ankush. Um so, let's
get into it.
So, let's imagine a common design. Um
you tend to build a system, and it
can do many things. Say, for example,
querying a database, sending an email,
um even checking a calendar, or looking
up an order, calling an API, and so on
and so forth.
The simplest approach over here would be
to give a model every tool definition on
every request. Every function name, um
every description, and even every JSON
schema will go into the prompt, whether
the user might need it or not.
So, that We are calling that as a fat
agent. At small scale, it feels fine.
With 10 tools as well, the model might
usually pick the right one. The demo
looks good.
Then, the product grows. Um
10 tools might become 30, or it will
keep on increasing, and eventually the
model starts calling the wrong function,
and starts confusing similar tools, may
invent
tool names, and even take longer to
respond.
The important point is, basically,
the design does not fail because one
tool is badly written. It fails because
every request is forced to carry the
entire catalog.
So, let's look here. There are, say for
example, uh 741 tools in your
uh
in your entire schema, but and it will
look, basically, take up to 127,000
tokens just to have all those tool
descriptions in it.
And this is even before the user user's
actual question is even considered. So,
basically, this will lead to context
overload and uh we need to manage that
properly.
So, on this slide we see why it is
failing and why the accuracy collapses
beyond a point. So, when you look at the
accuracy curve
with the 10 tools, fat agent will get
the tools right almost 78% of the times.
That is not perfect, but it's usable.
At almost 100 tools, the accuracy drops
to around 40%. Less than half of the
tools that are called are the correct
tools.
And if it grows beyond that, like say
for example, in over here, at 741 tools,
the accuracy will be a mere 13.6%.
So, in short, it's roughly one correct
tool out of eight tools.
So, when we compare it with the semantic
router, semantic router behaves very
differently. It stays above 83% across
the same catalog sizes.
That is because the model is not
choosing from hundreds of tools, it's
choosing from a small and relevant set.
One reason the fat agent fails is
because it's lost in the middle problem.
Model pays stronger attention to the
beginning and end of the long context.
When hundreds of tool schemas are packed
into the middle,
the model does not reliably use them.
So, we end up paying paying for a huge
prompt, and that prompts makes the
decisions even harder.
So,
two more reasons over here.
First is the latency and the second is
the cost. So, we saw in the earlier
slide that accuracy was a big problem.
Another issue is
with latency and cost over here as we
can see. So, like say for example, if we
have 741 tools, we saw that it requires
almost 127,000 tokens.
That will include the tool description
and the schema text. So, that cost is
basically being paid on every request.
At 100,000 requests a day, if you push
this into production,
you are sending in billions of tokens
and just to describe those tools.
And with just-in-time routing, the
prompt may include only three to five
relevant schemas, closer to about 1,000
tokens. That is roughly a 99% reduction
in tool context tokens.
Another issue is latency.
With fat agent approach,
time to first token grows as the tool
catalog grows because the model has to
process a larger prompt before it can
answer the user question.
So,
say for example, if you have 500 tools
in your agent, the fat agent path can
push first token latency past 5 seconds.
So, this is specifically important if
your product is real-time because this
will take longer time to respond. So,
which will make the design feel slow and
unpredictable. So, and with
semantic routing, it might feel more
responsive and it will be more real-time
in a way.
>> Here is the clean comparison. So, on the
left side, we have a
fat agent design and on the right side,
we have our semantic router design. So,
in the fat agent design, every schema
is loaded for every request, no matter
what the user asked.
And because of that, the catalog will
grow, the prompt will grow,
due to which the latency will rise and
accuracy will drop.
The agent also becomes one large
monolithic, which makes it hard to test,
risky to update, and even painful to
debug. But, in the case of
semantic routing design, the agent does
not start with every tool.
So, in this case, the router
first look at the user's query. It
retrieves the
three to five most relevant tool, and
then it injects only those into the
model call.
So, the context stays small, latency
stays stable,
and the accuracy holds because the model
is choosing from a focused list instead
of giant catalog.
This is Okay, so there is a one
important caveat here.
If you have fewer than 20 tools, a
router may be unnecessary.
Just load the tools directly. But, once
you passed 50 tools in the production
system,
then
justifying router-based
schema make more sense.
>> Thanks, Ankush. So, let's now look into
how semantic routing works.
If you have built a rack system
previously, this will feel pretty
similar to that. The difference is that
we will retrieve tools instead of the
documents.
So, at the first stage, say for example,
over here, each tool will have a clear
description. For example, a search
flights tool,
uh
a check calendar availability tool, or a
retrieve customer order status. Say for
example, the second step would be those
descriptions needs to get embedded and
stored in a vector index.
This is usually done offline when the
tool catalog is created or updated.
At the runtime, the user will ask a
question, we embed the user query with
the same embedding model.
Then, we search
that vector index for the tools with the
description that are closest to the
query.
So, the router will then return the top
K tools. Often, K would be three or five
tools that matches the user query. And
only those selected schemas will get
injected into the model call.
So, this is the whole pattern. At the
first step, you need to index tool
descriptions offline.
Then, retrieve relevant tools at runtime
and keep the model's context focused.
So, in short, the idea is pretty simple.
Semantic routing is basically a rack for
tools. Um if you already have an
embedding model and vector database in
your stack, most of the infrastructure
is already familiar to you.
>> Thank you, Sohil. Now, we will deep dive
into just-in-time context injection.
So, semantic routing
is the retrieval layer.
And just-in-time context injection is
the context management strategy. So, in
the case of
fat agent approach,
it loads everything before the query is
understood.
Due to which the model receives a huge
list of tools first, and then it tries
to reason through it.
Just-in-time context does the reverse.
It will wait
until the query is known, then
it will inject only the context needed
for that request.
I mean, this is not a new software idea.
We have used
lazy loading, just-in-time compilation,
and on-demand resource loading from
years.
We are just applying the simple and same
principle to the LLM context.
Anthropic has written about this pattern
with on-demand tooling loading through
MCP.
Their report token usage went from 150k
tokens down to 2,000, which is 98.7%
token reduction.
That is the signal. Large tool catalog
should not be dumped into the into every
prompt.
They should be retrieved when needed.
So,
moving to the next slide,
let's talk about how to evaluate this
fairly.
We measure four things here:
tool selection accuracy, time to first
token,
input tokens per request, and the
estimated cost per thousand call.
So, here for data sets,
we used Berkeley function calling
leaderboard,
Skills bench style scenarios, and
synthetic tool pools
that allow us to scale the number of
tools, so we can test at 10, 50,
100, 200, or even 1041 tools.
So, we ran the same queries in two
modes,
the fat agent one and the semantic
routing.
Same model, same answer key, same tool
catalog.
The only difference was whether the
model saw every tool
or only the routed tool.
We also swept K at 3, 5, 10 to
understand the trade-off.
So, the smaller K is the faster and
cheaper.
Larger K can be the
can recover more edge cases.
In practice, K equals 5 is a strong
default starting point. So, if you are
want to try this, you can default it to
five.
Here, K means the number of tools the
semantic router retrieves
and gives to the LLM for each user
queries.
Here are the benchmark result that we
got.
So, here is the result on the left side.
We see the fat agent accuracy line drop
sharply as the tool count grows.
It started around 78%
at 10 tool and then falls to around 13%
at 1041 tools.
But, in the case of router,
the router line stays above 83% because
the model stays stable.
From the model
points of view,
it always choosing the handful of tool,
even
if the real catalog contains 100.
On the right side,
time to first token shows the same
story.
The fat agent path gets slower as more
tool schemas are added.
At large catalog sizes,
the model spend noticeable time just
processing the prompt.
But in case of router,
it stays almost flat because of the
prompt size is under controlled.
This is the core lesson from the
benchmark.
The catalog can grow, but the model's
working set should stay small.
Now, on the next slide, we'll be
discussing about the implementation
pattern.
There are three steps in it.
Step one is offline.
So, build a catalog of tool.
For each tool,
store the name, description, schema.
Then, embed the description and store
it into a vector database. You can use
Chroma DB, you can use Pinecone, you can
use Quadrant. Whichever vector database
you are using.
Then, step two
will happen on every request.
Embed the user's query. Then, run the
nearest neighbor search.
And return the top K tools.
In the step three,
it will also happen on every request.
Fetch the schema for those selected
tools.
And then, pass only those schemas into
the model call and log which tool was
selected.
So, here, logging really matters.
So, let's say if you
miss something and if you want to
improve the description or you want to
tune the K,
you need
a good logging system that you can use
it.
So,
the runtime overhead is small, one
embedding call,
and one vector search.
The payoff is much smaller prompt and
more stable tool selection problem.
>> Awesome. So, now that you have learned
about the implementation pattern, I'll
take you through the code version of it,
which is pretty straightforward. So,
initially you need to loop through the
tool catalog, and for each tool, as
Ankur mentioned, embed the description,
store that in the vector database with
the tool name and other details.
At run time, embed that user query,
compare that query vector against the
stored tool vectors using cosine
similarity or vector search,
and then retrieve the
top most relevant tools, and then call
the model only with those schemas and
the function or tool parameter.
That final line is the most important
part because the model does not receive
all the tools, it only receive the
routed tools.
This works with any embedding model and
at and with any vector database. You can
start, as Ankur mentioned, you can start
with Quadrant or any other
database vector database locally, and
then move to a more managed vector store
later if needed. If you already have an
existing rag infrastructure, this is not
a new infrastructure as we mentioned
earlier, it is the same retrieval
pattern applied to the tool selection.
>> Thank you, Suhail.
Uh
Now,
we will discuss semantic routing in
action. So, imagine you have a 200 tool
agent.
A user asks, "Find me a flight
to New York next Wednesday.
The router embeds that query.
Returns tool like search flights, book
flight, calendar check.
The model sees only those relevant
schema, so it is much more likely to
call the correct tool.
But, if we load all 200 tools,
hotels tool, weather tool, emails tool,
sequels tool, or any unrelated workflow
tool,
it would all be competing for attention.
That is when model starts choosing the
wrong function.
Now, let's take a second query.
What is the weather in Paris right now?
The router
returns get weather and get forecast.
Flights tools are not injected. Hotels
tools are not injected.
They are simply not available at this
request.
This is an underrated benefit.
But, the router does not only add the
right tool, it also removes the wrong
tool from the model's choice set.
Now, in the next slide, we will discuss
implementation checklist. So, here is
the production checklist if somebody
wants to
uh
follow this along.
So, first,
get locked the tool in one place. So,
add name, description, schema, owner,
and the version.
Second is to build the index.
Embed each description
and store the vectors.
The third one is
write the router.
So, in this, embed the query,
then search the index, and take top K
and fetch schema.
The next one is the fourth one in which
a user need to wire it up into the agent
loop. So,
the model tool list should come from the
router, not from a hard-coded full
catalog.
Fifth is to evaluate. Run your test set
at K equals to three,
five,
and 10,
and then pick the smallest K that meets
your accuracy target.
Sixth is to monitor production.
Log selected tools, final tool calls,
failure,
and fallback usage.
Then re-embed tools when descriptions or
schema change.
This is not the 6-month
platform rewrite. For most team, it is a
focused sprint.
So, in the next slide,
we will discuss
what community already has confirmed.
This is not just the observation. So,
Anthropic has published on-demand tool
loading with MCP,
and reported a drop of 150k tokens to
2k, which is a huge reduction in tokens.
Developers
have raised similar issues in mainstream
agent and SDK projects,
pointing out that sending all tools
definition on every request
can increase latency,
token usage, and tool confusion.
Open proj open-source projects like MCP
zero
have also explored routing at very large
scale, including thousands of tool
across many servers.
And you can find form forums post from
builder
who hit tool confusion with only few
tools.
Long before they reach 100. So,
if you if your agent start failing as
tool are added,
it doesn't automatically means your
prompt are bad. It may means the
architecture is asking the model to
solve the wrong problem.
>> So, here we are just trying to say about
the
We are going to talk about the
open-source projects that we came
across.
So, one of them is of from Areilo Labs.
They have an open-source semantic router
project that you can easily use to test
locally for benchmarking,
Toolbench, and the Berkeley function
calling loader leaderboard are also
useful starting points. And for
practical guidance, you could read the
Anthropic MCP write-up. It explains why
on-demand tool loading matters and gives
a strong real-world signal for this
architecture. The point is that you
don't need to invent the ecosystem from
scratch. Those pieces already exist.
Next slide.
Sorry. Here it is.
Thank you. So, there are a few
trade-offs with this. The first risk
could be a router miss. So,
if the
So, the router may fail to retrieve the
tool the models need and handle that
with you could handle that with a feed
fallback. If the model cannot complete
the task, you could widen K, run a
second retrieval pass, or even route it
to a broader tool group. The second risk
would be weak tool descriptions. If your
descriptions are weak, embeddings will
end up being weak. Write descriptions in
the words users actually use and include
intent, action, and key entities along
with it.
The third risk would over here would be
rare tools. So, some tools may never
score high
unless their descriptions include the
right language. So, you need to monitor
data misses and rewrite those
descriptions accordingly.
And finally, just to conclude, do not
over-engineer small systems. If you have
10 or 15 tools, static loading may still
be fine. Routing generally pays off when
the catalog is large enough
that the prompt size, latency, or tool
confusion becomes a real production
problem.
So, a few
takeaways.
First thing is, as we discussed, tool
overload hurts accuracy. Loading every
schema into every prompt makes the
model's decision harder as the catalog
grows on.
The second one would be to
about tokens. It's like tokens are both
cost and latency.
Larger tool catalogs can add add tens of
thousands of tokens before the user's
actual request is handled. Semantic
routing can help fix that problem. The
When the catalog can be is large, the
model only sees the tools relevant to
the current query.
This is basically a rag for tools.
Index those descriptions, properly
retrieve at run time, and inject only
what is needed.
And finally, start simple. Use
K as five as a starting point, log every
decision, and evaluate against a real
test set.
And improve their tools descriptions
over time in case you get
incorrect tools being picked up. And the
goal is not to make these agents more
complicated. It's It is basically to
stop forcing the model to
reason over irrelevant tools.
So,
there are some references on this slide.
So, if you're building something, you
can use these references.
Like semantic routing libraries, tool
bench, Berkeley function calling
leaderboard, Anthropic MCP write-up, and
vector stores like Pinecone, Quadrant.
Thank you so much for watching this.
If this was useful, please share it with
someone building agents. They have
either already hit this wall or they're
about to.
You can scan our
LinkedIn QR codes on this slide to
connect with us. We are happy to
continue the conversation, share
resources,
or hear how others are approaching this
problem in their own system.
Thank you so much for watching this.
I'm Ankush.
This is Suheel, here. Thank you so much.
Yeah. Thanks, everyone.